[Musica]
c'è un'azienda che produce succhi di
frutta che qualche anno fa decide di
partecipare ad un pride a roma con una
campagna che a questo messaggio senza
pregiudizi aggiunti il messaggio sarà
poi ripetuto in centinaia di brick
distribuiti durante la manifestazione e
in altri punti di contatto dell'azienda
trasformando la dicitura senza zuccheri
aggiunti
questa azienda decide di prendere
posizione in maniera pubblica è molto
forte a favore dei diritti di tutti
c'è poi un'altra azienda che forse
l'azienda più famosa al mondo in merito
all'ampliamento sportivo che decide di
utilizzare l'immagine di uno sportivo
per la sua campagna e affianca a questa
immagine questo messaggio
credi in qualcosa anche se significa
sacrificare tutto questo sportivo però
non è uno sportivo come altri grandi
testimonial di questa azienda è il primo
giocatore di football americano ad
essersi inginocchiato durante
l'esecuzione dell'inno nazionale
per protestare contro la violenza da
parte della polizia nei confronti delle
popolazioni nere
questo giocatore quando viene coinvolto
per questa campagna non ha più una
squadra con cui giocare perché la sua
squadra non gli ha rinnovato il
contratto e nessun'altra seppur lui era
un campione ha voluto prenderlo in
squadra e il presidente della sua
nazione lo ha criticato apertamente per
questa protesta e in seguito criticherà
apertamente l'azienda per averlo
coinvolto in questa campagna ancora una
volta un azienda mette al centro della
propria campagna di comunicazione di
marketing una presa di posizione
politica molto forte e anche
provocatoria terzo esempio un'altra
azienda che si occupa sempre di
abbigliamento invece di invogliare i
propri clienti a comprare nuovi prodotti
li invita a riparare quelli vecchi e lo
fa in maniera concreta inviando dei
furgoncini per esempio negli stati uniti
ma anche in europa per permettere a
questi clienti di riparare gratuitamente
i prodotti sul sito di questa azienda
leggiamo siamo in business per salvare
il nostro pianeta è uno dei brand più
impegnati a sensibilizzare l'opinione
pubblica a favore dei cambiamenti
climatici per combattere i cambiamenti
climatici e lo fa in maniera concreta
attraverso centinaia di azioni e
sostenendo migliaia di piccole
associazioni in tutto il mondo
questi sono solo alcuni degli esempi che
vedono le aziende prendere posizione
quotidianamente su problematiche che
riguardano l'opinione pubblica mondiale
nella nostra società globalizzata le
aziende ei brand hanno avuto sempre più
ampio spazio di manovra
diventando protagonista della vita di
miliardi di persone attraverso i loro
prodotti i loro servizi orientandoli
tuttavia però solo in senso consumistico
senza considerare le conseguenze appunto
del loro agire ma per fortuna la rotta
sembra essere timidamente cambiata no
non sto parlando della responsabilità
sociale d'impresa così come viene
definita nel libro verde
comunità europea pubblicato già nel 2001
ovvero nell'integrazione volontaria
delle preoccupazioni sociali ed
ecologiche delle imprese nelle loro
operazioni commerciali e nei loro
rapporti con le parti interessate
sto parlando di qualcosa che va oltre
sto parlando del cosiddetto brand
attivismo le aziende stanno assumendo un
ruolo nuovo facendosi portavoce di
istanze che riguardano il cambiamento
rispetto a dei grandi temi globali come
quello appunto dell'inquinamento e del
cambiamento climatico nella crisi
economica della povertà dell'emigrazione
della debolezza dei sistemi governativi
della corruzione dell'accesso
all'istruzione della diffusione dei
diritti
queste aziende stanno traducendo in
azione un'attenzione che nella nostra
società appunto globalizzata e molto
tangibile e lo stanno facendo perché
stanno ascoltando la generazione ze y i
giovani sempre più impermeabile al
fascino dei consumi è sempre più attenti
a come sta il nostro pianeta queste
aziende stanno agendo perché stanno
ascoltando una grande fascia della
popolazione mondiale che non consuma più
in maniera acritica e che presta
attenzione alle proprie scelte giorno
per giorno che cos'è dunque il brand
activism e perché rappresenta
un'evoluzione timidamente rivoluzionaria
dell'idea di impresa per poter
rispondere a questa domanda dobbiamo
prima concentrarci a capire cos'è un
brand cos'è un brand se non un insieme
di valori che vengono trasferiti nei
prodotti e nei servizi dell'azienda che
cos'è un brand se non appunto l'insieme
di questi valori intangibili delle
proposte delle promesse e dei punti di
forza che un brand fa nei confronti del
proprio pubblico nei confronti dei
propri clienti e nel modo in cui vuole
essere riconosciuto dal mercato
il brand pd per utilizzare le parole di
coter e sarkar gli autori del testo più
importante sull'argomento che si chiama
appunto brand atti di from pur post to
action
loro dicono che il brand attivismo
consiste negli sforzi dell'impresa per
promuovere impedire o influenzare
riforme o stati d'inerzia sociali
politici economici o ambientali con il
fine di promuovere impedire i
miglioramenti della società il brand
anche quindi fa sì che le aziende
considerino il prodotto e il profitto
derivante dalla vendita del prodotto
come uno strumento di azione per
sostenere cause ed impatto sociale e
politico questo sforzo e questo impegno
per utilizzare sempre le parole di coter
stargard può essere progressivo o
regressivo progressivo che può mirare a
migliorare evidentemente il mondo in cui
viviamo
regressivo che mira in maniera
conservatore a mantenere lo status quo
allora qui adesso noi dobbiamo un attimo
fermarci e farci una domanda è appunto
l'ennesima trovata di marketing da parte
di un gruppo di multinazionali la
risposta è sì solo se le multinazionali
che aziende si impegnano a favore
distanze giuste per coprire per così
dire
il loro agire poco giusto si parla per
esempio di greenwashing quando le
aziende si impegnano a favore di cause
legate all'ambiente
all'esterno e non agiscono poi in
maniera sostenibile al proprio interno
stesso discorso vale per il social watch
ico più in generale per il world war
washing cioè quell impegno da parte
appunto delle aziende solo in maniera di
facciate allora in quali ambiti
dovrebbero impegnarsi le aziende che
vogliono passare all'azione come sempre
quando si parla di marketing
comunicazione aziende un po il mio
lavoro la risposta e dipende dipende da
chi si è dalla propria storia dal
proprio ambito di azione dalla propria
sensibilità
se quindi normale e giusto pensare che
una multinazionale si possa impegnare su
tematiche di larga scala che coinvolgono
milioni di persone è altrettanto giusto
pensare che ci sia e che si possa
passare all'azione da parte di piccole
aziende che abbiano quindi nel loro
agire una ricaduta sul territorio
allora il termine glocal coniuga proprio
questa attitudine un pensiero globale ad
un azione locale che poi è il motivo per
cui oggi io qui parlo di brand attivi
cioè nella possibilità di impegnarsi
anche in piccola scala per migliorare il
mondo è il luogo in cui viviamo
qualche mese fa sono stato alla biennale
d'architettura di venezia il cui tema
era come vivremo insieme
nel prossimo futuro in questo pianeta e
in un padiglione di era una casa
completamente
destrutturata in ogni singola parte di
questa casa destrutturata era ben messa
in evidenza alla provenienza perché
appunto una casa e un mondo e il mondo e
ovviamente la nostra casa ma soprattutto
oggi il mondo nella nostra casa allora
da dove partire nel concreto se si vuole
passare all'attivismo di marca come
detto bisogna osservare la propria
realtà ascoltare i propri interlocutori
dare voce alla propria sensibilità e
bisogna porsi tutta una serie di domande
gli imprenditori che decidono di passare
all'azione devono porsi una serie di
domande devono chiedersi per esempio
come possono dare valore sociale al
profitto che generano come possono
modificare il loro modo di produrre le
relazioni che hanno per esempio al
proprio interno con i dipendenti con
fornitori come possono quindi modificare
innanzitutto la propria realtà per poter
poi incidere sul resto del mondo è un
imprenditore dopo essersi fatto queste
domande inevitabilmente si chiederà mi
conviene io non voglio adesso qui citare
dei grafici non voglio mostrarvi i
valori delle azioni di borsa che
crescono ma ci sono numerosi studi e
numerosi indicatori che ci raccontano
che in quelle aziende dove si è deciso
di passare all'azione semplifico
ovviamente la qualità della vita
aziendale è aumentata e soprattutto è
molto migliorata e ovviamente questo
miglioramento ha riguardato anche il
profitto
concludo dicendo se non ora quando
e ora il momento per le aziende di
passare all'azione e considerare quindi
l'attivismo di marca come non un costo
ma un investimento profittevole per
migliorare oggi il mondo in cui viviamo
e soprattutto per lasciarlo migliore
alle generazioni future
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]